bars in clark county will remain closed
the covid 19 mitigation and management
task force voted unanimously today
to keep current restrictions in place
denise
so that means bars pubs taverns
breweries distilleries and wineries that
don't serve food
cannot welcome guests back just yet as
well as no service at bar tops
8 news now reporter kristen drummond has
the latest
it's tough i mean there's a lot of
people that are out of work jonathan
fine owns a few bars in town
including the mint a business forced to
close for a second time last month
following a directive by governor steve
sisilak
it's a confusing time it's a frustrating
time the mandate impacting bars and
other alcohol serving establishments was
set to expire thursday night
but the covet 19 mitigation and
management task force was given the
authority to extend closures
and unanimously decided to do that in
clark county
the chairman acknowledges the choices
made impacts livelihoods
and lives this is not something that any
of us take lightly
and i know that the decision though
seeming to baffle some who call the vote
unfair i think that there's more of an
issue in casinos and larger
you know larger stores that are allowed
to stay open it makes no sense that
certain places can
and bars can't frankie lee owns
frankie's uptown in downtown summerlin
he says the situation is a hardship for
businesses
we can't take this much longer
financially i don't think it's
it's not good for anybody lee and fein
say health and safety remain a top
priority
the two owners though want more clarity
during these challenging circumstances
we'll all make it through this it's just
it's a matter of what kind of a toll
does this take on our community
the task force may address the closures
in clark county again
in a couple of weeks in the newsroom
kristen drummond 8 news now
a final note here the task force does
work with local leaders to examine the
data and review assessment as well as
those action plans
six counties were flagged just last week
for having a high virus transmission
risk